which brings us to the first and most
important thing to talk about
which is your sustainable approach to
living
and and growing and harvesting your own
food
right like you've been preparing for
exactly this kind of a situation
like doomsday in general you're a
prepper
yeah i've been like a prepper for years
and like
i i really never wanted to say like i
told you so or anything like that
but i mean we've been like kind of like
obsessively getting ready and just kind
of like waiting for the fall society and
uh i think it's gonna happen in stages
like this is like the first wave man oh
my god
it's so scary i mean i don't want to uh
like
bomb everybody out but like the other
night
i plugged into my youtube search
the two words great depression i thought
you know maybe
like there's some videos to put into
context like what we're facing right now
and the general consensus seem to be
that this looks like
a greater depression than the great
depression
and it's just so scary to think of that
uh
and and i mean [ __ ] so here we are
well the good thing is you know humanity
has
survived all of the craziest things that
have happened
you know like the depression sucked
through bionic plague
sucked like world war one and two sucked
but you know
right we're very hard to eliminate you
know
and so i think it's more than like
being like oh no this is terrible we're
not in like the cushiest times i think
it's just kind of happens in cycles
especially with us like
reproducing so quickly and like taking
over so much the planet and everything
and so
it's kind of uh one of those things
where we can all get that victim
mentality or we could think about
like okay how can we like evolve with
the times
and how can we take the initiative and
you know instead of welling
dwelling in our situation like take the
initiative and find a way to get out of
it
get ready this is going to be gnarly
pretty gnarly
kind of normal are we ready yeah
what's up denver
[Music]
women can paint their boobs and show
them on instagram
so i figure i should be able to paint my
dick and do whatever i want
make some noise for my brother
[Applause]
wait let me inspect for crabs this time
when my buddies lit that stuff right
away i knew
i [ __ ] up
[Music]
i'm not doing this to hurt your dad
you're gonna hurt me you're gonna piss
me off